شاكيرا تنتقم من بيكي شيرين في الكويت
ليله عبد المجيد عبد الله والمواجهه باتت
اكيده بين كريستيانو وميسي في الرياض
اليكم الابراج في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
حظيت اغنيه شاكيرا الجديده بتفاعل واسع
منصات التواصل حول العالم الاسبوع الماضي
وتجاوز عدد مشاهداتها ال 120 مليون مشاهده
خلال اربعه ايام واعتبرها متابعون رد
الفعل الاوضح منها على انفصالها عن بيكيه
العام الماضي والذي طالته معظم كلمات
الاغنيه بالانتقاد بطريقه غير مباشره
واعطت المغنيه الكولومبيه من اصل لبناني
انطباعا واضحا من خلالها بانها اقوى بعد
الانفصال
كما حقق وسم شيرين في الكويت تفاعل كبير
على منصات التواصل في العالم العربي
شرين عبد الوهاب اولى حفلاتها بعد ازماتها
الاخيره غالب الدموع في الحفل وارادت من
خلاله على ما يبدو ارسال رساله لجمهورها
بانها لا تزال قويه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
زيارتها المثيره للجدل مؤخرا للمغني فضل
شاكر الذي يواجه احكام قضائيه في لبنان
قائله بان زيارته كانت زياره عزيزه على
قلبها بحسب ما ورد في مقطع فيديو متداول
لها على تويتر من الحفل قالت فيه صباط او
بياده الجيش اللبناني على دماغي من فوق
او بياده الجيش الثاني على دماغي من فوق
[موسيقى]
التواصل في السعوديه على نطاق الواسع مع
ليله عبد المجيد عبد الله في موسم الرياض
وكان الموسم الاسبوع الماضي حافلا
بالموسيقى بمشاركه نخبه من نجوم الغناء
العربي كاظم الساهر كارول سماحه مروان
خوري وديانا حداد
بطولات
للمبتود ظل من جرحك تعال
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
واخيرا تاكدت المواجهه المرتقبه بين
كريستيانو رونالدو وميسي في منافسه بين
فريق يضم نجوم من نادي الهلال والنصر
السعوديين وفريق نادي باريس سان جيرمان
على كاس موسم الرياض في التاسعه عشر من
يناير الحالي وسلم تركي ال الشيخ رئيس
مجلس اداره الهيئه العامه للترفيه رونالدو
شارك كابتن فريق موسم رياض الذي يستعد
للمباراه للمنتظره في استاد الملك فهد
الدولي بالرياض وشاهد الاستاذ هذا الاسبوع
ايضا فوز نادي برشلونه في نهائي كاس
السوبر الاسباني على حساب ريال مدريد